Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so Avengers infinity
war is coming up Marvel has never been doing
better, but Marvel fans are more pissed than
ever, so I'm going to explain what's going
on as we headed to infinity war the last couple
years this weird thing has been happening
at Marvel where there comics have been doing
steadily worse and worse, but their movies
have been doing better and better they've
been making more money they been doing well
with the critics, which is almost unheard
of, but this past year.
They almost hit rock bottom they will be saved
by Avengers infinity war I'll explained how
that's going to work.
There is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway
two it's a $20 comixology giftcard.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so right
now Marvel is blowing it up, but when most
people think about Marvel they think about
the movies they don't think about the comics
is much even though there are hundreds and
hundreds of stories from all the characters
published each year.
You have to consider the total comic book
sales for all publishers combined worldwide
last year was somewhere like a closed $1 billion
in Marvel does that was just one of its movies
so the movies or a multibillion-dollar industry
there comics you have to consider that there
like a percentage of total comic book sales
are in the hundreds of millions.
So it's a fraction of that.
So a lot of people don't always pay attention
when really big stuff is happening in the
comics even though there is a really big thing
getting ready to happen.
The next big arc for Marvel comics is called
Captain America secret Empire and he seems
like he's going to be the central focus of
their big comic book event later this year
that will spill into next year.
So remember next year is infinity war so it's
gonna be in avengers year they'll of already
had their first big Spider-Man movie and typically
the comics follow the movies now used to be
the other way around, like the reason they
did Civil War to do like the reason they call
that that was because they had Captain America
Civil War coming out even though in the Civil
War title there was very little actual civil
war going on not the best big comic book event
that Marvel's had DC rebirth did way better
in that gets into why people are super upset
because Marvel comics right now.
Unlike the movies are tanking their comic
sales are a fraction of DC sales were the
last several years they have been pounding
DC in sales, but this past year they have
this big diversity push they had all knew
all different now.
They got rid of Iron Man they got rid of the
hold.
They replaced them with other characters in
their titles and their sales are tanking people
are pissed.
So if you don't read comics and you don't
know what's going on.
They had their Civil War two event at the
end of that they didn't quite kill off Tony
Stark, but they effectively killed him off
in another character called re-re-Williams
took over his invisible Iron Man comic with
the name iron hard, so she's wearing the armor.
Her AI is actually made of Tony Stark's consciousness.
So he still around, but he's not Iron Man
anymore Dr. doom stole his armor and stole
the title, so remember I said, the comics
follow the movies now will Sony has a big
Spider-Man movie coming out what a coincidence
that Peter Parker is the only character left
on top he's actually doing pretty well in
the marvel comics right now he sort of like
the benefactor the Tony Stark of the avengers.
He's the one with all the money because is
this big billion dollar corporation.
He has his own version of the avengers tower.
So he's kind of like the Tony Stark of the
Marvel universe right now but he's the only
one, everybody else is like a slightly different
version of their character as the female Thor
is the Amadeus Cho version of the hold.
And even though the doing a lot of really
interesting things most comic book fans that
like the first couple issues not really piston
like okay we want the characters that we love
to come back.
So Marvel because their sales are doing so
poorly will probably do their own version
of DC rebirth in another year to if they don't
do it by infinity war it will happen the year
after that.
Just because they have this big Captain America
event that's coming up so the probably do
that and then decide whether or not just completely
reboot everything the way the DC did this
past year I did a couple videos about it but
what happened is is DC sales had gotten so
bad that Geoff John's and the other powers
that be just decided to do a complete reboot
where they brought back all the changes that
they had made a couple years ago with the
new 52, so people were pissed during the new
52 there were a couple characters that may
be like may be like those comics, but overall
sales started to plummet because all the characters
that people loved and gone away a completely
rewritten all this continuity.
So what they did is they press the hard reset
eject button and we got DC rebirth was amazing,
everybody loved it and it is selling like
gangbusters there outselling Marvel by a crazy
amount way more than you would everything
possible.
So it's a very clear indicator that people
are not happy with what Marvel is doing right
now and there really happy the DC brought
back all this old stuff, so you can do the
math.
Even though the people at Marvel and people
at DC get along really really well.
They look at what each other's doing all the
time.
So Mark my words sales continue to plummet
Marvel will do their own version of DC rebirth
of it totally caught something different than
I can a call at Marvel rebirth, but because
infinity war is happening next year they will
probably target that were some big event and
they'll use that is a way to reboot all their
characters without completely destroying everything
that everyone's love for so long.
So if you been reading comics for a long time.
This is nothing new to you.
There's always like a stretch of comics or
some big story arc that just doesn't pay off
Marvel and DC will always double down and
come back with something that's even better,
but the problem is is that it takes a long
time to publish a comic and it takes a long
time to make a movie.
So if there's like a movie that Marvel has
in the future.
It doesn't do really well.
It'll take them a little while to come back
with something even better, but I think the
best example of that are the Thor movies as
a franchise Thor has done really well at the
box office critically not so much if you go
back after watching Captain America Civil
War and try to watch the first-order film
or even the second Thor film just shake your
head in wonder what's going on even watching
the first avengers film almost feels like
you're watching a long episode of TV because
the way they filmed it, so a lot of those
early problems that Marvel had he slowly ironed
out technical issues the way they film things
looks better now but Thor Ragnarok does because
it takes so long to make these sequels is
going to be one of the best weirdest films
ever in the weird part is the reason why it's
gonna be so cool so you have all these great
actors, the problem is is that when Marvel
was first getting started with its movies.
It was such a big financial risk that they
tried to make the most least objectionable
movies possible like they just sanded all
the edges off all the interesting stuff down,
so that nobody would be upset they wouldn't
offend anyone.
Nothing would be weird but then Kevin fight
he was able to sort of like break off and
do his own thing and now they are free to
be as weird as they want they earn that trust
from the fans.
So it took a while to get there but you look
at movies like Dr. strange and like ant Man
totally weird compared to the straight up
avengers films but did really well financially
for the type of movies that they were.
You know very small in comparison.
So that is why I'm so excited about what's
going on with Marvel movies just the fact
that they're embracing that weirdness, but
staying true to the characters and that is
the same reason that the comics are taking
right now is because comic book fans feel
like they're not being true to those characters
like you have and Iron Man comic book with
no Iron Man in it.
Why would you want to read that you know a
lot of the comic book sales now are driven
by movie watchers that want to read adventures
with those characters.
You can't do that with any of marvels comics
right now all of the straight up heroes that
you see in the movies are off doing other
things, or their dead Kevin fight he and all
the directors, producers, actors have teased
that infinity war in the movies is going to
be the culmination of all the types of things
that they been doing since phase 1 going forward
after that everything is going to be very
different.
Even though though still be very true to the
characters.
Now what is that mean.
So we haven't seen Thor Ragnarok yet but they're
talking about more buddy road trip type movies
where you have team ups like you have Iron
Man in a Spider-Man movie will be a lot more
crossovers more small weird movies so like
the next time you see Captain America movie
you might see him with Black Panther or like
they might do that instead of doing another
Captain America sequel.
That doesn't mean that they're not going to
do sequels anymore but it is going to do a
lot more mixing and matching with characters
infinity war is really that point of transition,
so that is probably when Bill target for their
Marvel comics rebirth for they bring everybody
back in new interesting ways.
But they do it in a way that's true to those
comic book characters see you guys can let
me know what you think about Marvel comics
in this past year.
Most people have been complaining like most
people just a really unsatisfied, but how
long you think it's gonna be before they roll
back all these changes you have to imagine
that the same thing was kind of happening
at DC films like their slowly working the
kinks out.
So it's like okay we have some really awesome
things here, but the characters aren't exactly
the way we want them to be.
So will fix this a little bit going forward
everybody to be happy.
It'll be wonderful, but publishing comics
making movies it just takes a lot of time.
So even though they might already be making
those changes they definitely Artie made those
changes the DC films.
But Marvel comics you might not see that pay
off till later this year or even next year.
So if you're hardcore, comic book fan you
know that you just stick it out it'll all
be fine in the end it is might take a little
while to get there.
There was some new Spider-Man homecoming and
legends footage that just dropped.
So I'll probably do videos for that next,
then some game of thrones I want to post and
they've been talking about Green Lantern,
so I'll try to get that stuff out as fast
as possible a whole bunch of really cool comic
book news that just dropped while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here to
learn all about Superman black costume hype
and you can click here to learn all about
the future of X 23 and the Wolverine character
inside x men universe you thank you so much
for watching everybody thought five I'll see
you guys tonight!